why can't you just admit you missed the
turnoff because I didn't miss it you're
the one navigator you're literally
holding the map that's because you fell
asleep
[Music]
yep he's dead well it's okay hey it's
okay I really appreciate all the help
you hit these have given me so far
it's been great but I have one more
favor to ask you do you see that force
field force field plus yeah that one big
blue one
my friend is trapped on the other side
of that force field and if you help me
go and save him I'll help you find a way
out of here I don't think we can do that
well the other option is we can deal
with treat meats friends up there but
you're both unarmed so let's just go
[Music]
my skin at home
Carol it's now markings for the pain
do not stop the band we're outside of
the circle and this is the only thing
with wheels for miles they'll do
anything to take it from No thank you
not interested not interested no thank
you
we don't want your stuff I'm just
looking for his weapon thank you don't
thank you get my horse friendís wait
wait you have to promise you'll give me
a ride first wait what do you know he's
just up that hill 290 Northwest from
here cool
Pickman
[Music]
what does on Bobby snuck in here
[Music]
sit tight buddy we're coming to save you
Wow I'm gonna get you
[Music]
[Music]
Sam here take this gun helping
no no dammit where's Niko
ten Mississippi nine eight
Oh No
[Music]
[Music]
no no you promised new brothers we have
a deal we had a deal
[Music]
you promise
[Music]
I can't believe it so quiet now
oh yeah it's a little too quiet almost
like we're the only ones left you know
what that means we're gonna have to beat
them to death with our pants
like real men
I don't know after everything they've
done for us I feel kind of bad just
killing these hippies hippies
we're not hippies we're libertarians
yeah I'd like to tell you a quick story
we were shooting this video we actually
all downloaded pub G mobile and played
it together in the evening as some of
the most fun we've ever had they've done
a great job porting it to the phone so
we'd like to play yourself you can play
for free by clicking the link in the
description below thank you to pub g/mol
for sponsoring this video thank you to
you for watching and please consider
subscribing
[Music]
you